there was another nfl record that was
tied yesterday and there's a little
controversy behind this so this one's
interesting so the broncos are playing
the ravens and baltimore's got a
legendary rushing attack they have a
running quarterback so for the past 42
games they've had at least 100 yards
rushing as a team that's a pretty good
streak that's two and a half years so
they were on the verge of tying the
all-time record on sunday they needed
100 yards and they would tie the 1970s
era pittsburgh steelers frank o'hara's
rocky blair
tie them for the most consecutive games
of a team rushing for at least 100 yards
now they're winning the game 23-7 it's
over they take over the ball in the
final seconds and it's an automatic
victory formation right you go there
lamar jackson gets the ball takes a knee
game over john harbaugh knew the coach
of the ravens knew they were four yards
shy of the record so he puts his offense
out there they run a real play lamar
jackson buys a little time finds a
little opening picks up four or five
yards they tie the record they get
exactly 100 or 101 and they're in the
record books they're tied so next week
they have the record all to themselves
so
vic fangio the coach for the broncos got
all bent out of shape right he's old
school he had a problem with that his
quote was i thought it was kind of
[ __ ] but i expected from them you
know 37 years in pro ball and i've never
seen something like that but it was to
be expected we expected it grow up i
mean if something like that is going to
bother you so much maybe you should go
back to being an assistant coach the
rest of your life give me a break no one
was bothered by that at all that's an
incredible an achievement a team
achievement what's wrong he didn't bury
your nose and it they didn't score a
touchdown and run over to you and spike
the ball in your face four yards at the
end of the game i mean this this reminds
me of old school baseball mentalities
where they broke the code john harbaugh
needs to be hit with a pitch next week
maybe they could throw a football at him
right i mean gerard
harbaugh needs to be hit with a pitch
next week this is absolute [ __ ] and
i will tell you why tom because i'm old
enough to remember when greg schiano was
the head coach of tampa bay and he had
his guys playing through the whistle
whatever that day and teams would go and
they'd take a knee in the final minute
and he'd have guys submarine and getting
in there and every coach in the world
said that's bs what are you doing you're
trying to get people hurt out here play
the game play the game with integrity
this was not playing with integrity
listen you want you can't have it both
ways guys you cannot have this reminds
me of like when i believe it was j.r
smith he was one rebound away from a
triple double one day and he took the
inbounds pass with like 12 seconds left
threw it up against his own backboard
grabbed it so he got the he got the
triple-double on the rebound any this
goes kind of back to what we were saying
i think anything that happens
inorganically is bs anything that
happens in organically is nonsense if i
were fangio and they did that then i'm
like okay that's how you guys want to
play it i'm diving in there in the next
play no no no no no diving in there
diving low
i thought gerard would be on the side of
that wouldn't have a problem with it no
no not at all no gerard here's your
sense here's what i disagree with you
want to play oh okay you want to play it
that way that way
running for four yards that's all he did
he didn't try to hurt anybody what yeah
i was out of victory no no no no they
did not want it they were lined up in
victory for them
and the broncos knew it was he said he
was expecting it he should know it was
coming no one's no one was you know in
jeopardy
i'm gonna strike you maybe to the core
new york giants because i grew up in new
york giants michael strahan right hated
it brett favre hated it right hated it
still don't think straight hand has the
records it is that so there's
consistency hated okay hated they hated
they hated it do you think farmer went
down on purpose absolutely not only that
but the the right tackle was it bhakti
it wasn't back to our background
whatever the right tackle was i heard
was beyond livid beyond limit because he
made it his job to make sure that he was
not going to give up that sack right and
he held down a hall of famer whose only
goal that whole day was to get one sack
hold him to nothing
and then farve gives him a cherry and
far to this day says it was a blown call
shut up inconsistent or not i i draw a
distinction between team
goals or team records and individual
records so someone throwing up the ball
off the the backboard to get that tenth
rebound that's all individual the
baltimore ravens are taking pride in a
team
oriented
record
beyond that they didn't know they did
they did get they didn't get it they got
it come on man they didn't get it well
the official box score says they do have
but if they were down by 10 points
they'd probably be throwing the ball and
not running let's let's go back let's go
back to the giants i have
nothing but respect for eli manning
because apparently when it came out that
uh geno smith was going they wanted to
give geno smith some snap snaps the the
the plan was manning was going to start
the first half of the last three games
and then geno smith would come in the
second half so that he could he could
keep his record right and danning to his
credit goes absolutely freaking not
either i'm the quarterback or i'm not
and they said well then gino's missed a
quarterback he's like all right then you
just missed the quarterback i have
respect for that yeah but i got nothing
but respect i don't think you can lump
what happened yesterday in that game
with some of these other analogies like
i feel bad for that left tackle or
whoever it was for the packers because
that's a highlight that's going to be
played forever right and if that if that
record wasn't legit or if did take a
dive i mean that that hurts him in
contract negotiations let me ask you
this tom if they were if they were at
101 okay let's let's inverse it if they
were at 101 yards
and the broncos decided that they were
gonna all out zero blitz right to hold
them from so get them from 100 to 999
would you say that that's dog [ __ ] would
you say that that's bush league being
zero blitzing with 15 seconds to go down
by 10.
borderline so there you go yeah but i
but there's a difference because
they weren't like offense no they
weren't humiliating the other team they
really weren't now if they had if they
were looking to set the all-time scoring
record or tie the all-time scoring
record they had a 30-point lead and they
dust off you know
their their top running back who had
been sitting for two quarters and bring
them in to get one last score
that's that's humiliating yeah george
brings up a good point but i guess the
reason why we're we're falling prey
tom to your argument is that it's
probably what the
900th most important
record there is nobody cares
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]
you